you're getting married why you get
married some people think I'm straight
yeah my girlfriend's half Greek there's
a chance our kid may be born a block of
feta cheese a hundred percent absolutely
but definitely gonna have one eyebrow
I'm going to your wedding you are yeah
I'm gonna go to your wedding they're not
wear baseball jerseys you gotta buy
really the thing is I don't have any
suits
what's up back at the bar hey I'm still
my boy Yanis poppets aka Freddie feta
cheese what do you think is the most
childish thing people do as adults
everything that an adults do now is
childish right yeah nobody wants to have
a kid now nobody can believe I have a
child
they're like why'd you're 33 you and you
just threw your whole life away it's
like if this is a hundred years ago I'd
almost be dead right now
I never tuberculosis my kid would be 28
remember when we were kids you saw your
dad he was wearing a suit yeah 15 years
old yeah my dad had fought in four Wars
by the time he was 24 I mean look at you
you're 42 imagine your dad saw you like
this imagine my grandfather's oh my god
doing skits doing skits like you're
getting paid this is a job yeah yeah no
I want you to look into that camera to
apologize I am sorry I'm sorry
would you rather accidentally sext your
mom or sext your dad I'd like to sex my
dad cause it would be funny yeah my mom
I already do sex er so I don't think I'd
sext my mom but I I sent a dick pic you
know it sends to a girl and then I
accidentally I tagged my mom like I I
attached my mom was right then yeah she
never responded it was a remote there
was where I stuff to remote control my
sweatpants yeah I don't show my actual
penis and I have I mean I I'm half Irish
I next stupid question would you rather
be known as The Crying guy or the lotion
guy I'd rather be known as a lotion guy
why because it sounds like a better time
yeah I cry a lot I am known as the
lotion guy to myself we all got secrets
cuz when I was a young kid I wasn't the
brightest kid
I stuck my dick in a vapor rub just to
see if it burned that's what happened he
says a lot true story yeah Joe
I'm the crying kid you are Ike yeah
crock how many times have I cried to15
yeah counted because they were so
jarring would you rather go on a hot air
balloon blindfolded or go to a ballet
with earplugs in hot-air-balloon planful
you'd rather do that yeah because now
get the butterflies in my stomach
yeah a little bit of a high if I go to a
ballet so I'm gonna close my eyes and
fall asleep I'd like to go on the
hot-air balloon ride with you and
blindfold you and then push you right
overboard yeah I'd like to watch you
fall and explode into federal crime that
will you like yep that's what I want to
do I'd like to walk you up to a hill in
Poughkeepsie yeah make you dig your own
hole yeah shoot you into it yeah all
right so did you have a good time I had
a great time cause you know you're my
best friend
and I got you a gift Wow yeah I didn't
get you anything
all right cuz you Greek I want to get
you a bag of feta crumble yeah it's kind
of like it's a also wedding gift oh my
god are you when your fiance it's too
much yeah yeah no thank you I love you
man yeah yeah yeah you smell like olive
oil organic dude that stinks that is
organic huh yeah that comes right that
came right from a Greeks woman
you